reese witherspoon tells ET she's ready  for the Cruel Intentions TV show yeah  I'm excited  her co-star Sarah Michelle Gellar is  returning for the NBC revival set 15  years after the 1999 classic there's a  good friend of mine and our kids are in  preschool together so I'm really excited  it's a lot of the original people  involved I want to grease of course was  a net Hargrove in the original the show  will focus on a net and Sebastian's son  but we have our fingers crossed for a  Reese cameo the actress stepped out for  these stand-up two cancer's New York's  standing room only event in New York on  Sunday obviously cancer affects so many  people in my life and everyone's lives I  mean it's literally I don't know a  person whose life has been affected by  this devastating disease my husband lost  his father seven years ago to lung  cancer and it has been a mission of his  to raise as much money as possible for  cancer research